when you go around you bet dancing you
certainly knows how big that tattoo we
have you added to it is that the same
size it is from mid-back all the way
down Davis again
was it always got to be that big or was
that always the plan or did you just
spray you know what's funny after he
goes my ass look big in this stuff
actually I got sick I had after I got
malaria I wrote a you call a book at
least I call it a [ __ ] at least
everything I wanted to do and you know
life short yeah and I changed my
perspective and I always wanted a big
tattoo it's not a bitter tattoo I can
see there though this is a different
well that's a different tattoo okay it's
not my fault it's this is a vulgar
question but I will ask it no it's not
that voter but three three days it took
to do it yes yes three sessions three
sessions so how much that cost well the
guy that did it is actually a
exceptional artist yes but he's not just
a tattooist he's Oh
yes it's very good an artist with a butt
fetish roses with worth it you're not
telling so much what is it in the
thousands could you buy a car you do
realize that many people would have paid
you to do it and give it cuz you have
you know you've had quite a wild past
you've been through periods wellness
have you escaped have you escaped
without a tattoo yeah no ink I didn't I
couldn't decide on anything that I
wanted to live with forever I had that
problem with women for a long time I'm
happily married down for 15 years well
talk well if you'd like a tattoo Cheryl
dab hand yeah no seriously she give her
an e tones of ink she's off let me think
on that
no but you you wouldn't you tattooed the
guy who taught you gentle this is you
tattooing Nico and now this is what you
turn to that's how it started is that
sunglasses or glasses it wasn't intended
to well he wears glasses okay the idea
was his signature look is quite known
and he wears big thick glasses they kind
of look like a V as in the end yeah my
bad but then a hawk because I think he's
got a really special heart yeah my
initials cuz I did the tattoo oh is that
your initials at the end CC oh you
trying to get the pen to work
I crash into another car right but it's
supposed to be a stunt but what happens
is the car gets out of out of control
and I actually do crash into the car
like Jamie get out of the way Tom you're
an Irishman you think these people
except you was one of the